what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and merry Christmas and happy holidays
to everybody who recently celebrated I
hope it was good for everybody and I
hope everybody has a great New Year's as
we go into another year we get closer to
Avengers Secret Wars the next Avengers
in-game level type of movie from Marvel
Studios and based off of everything that
we've heard so far anything is fair game
for Secret Wars the Multiverse is going
to be heavily involved and not like in
Multiverse of Madness this movie is
going to be exploring a lot of different
multiverses and a lot of different
Heroes and possibly villains are going
to all be coming together on screen in
one Universe it's pretty much the ideal
scenario for every Marvel fan out there
The Avengers the X-Men the Fantastic
Four and a bunch of different variants
of these characters all together on
screen pretty much what we've been
waiting for since the Inception of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and even way
before then where we still had the fox
Marvel movies now we've talked a lot
about some characters that could
possibly show up in Avengers Secret Wars
but today we're going to go over all the
characters from other universes who
could show up in this movie and in fact
it looks like Kevin feige the president
of Marvel Studios does have some pretty
big plans to bring other characters from
other universes into the main MCU for
Avengers Secret Wars So today we're
going to go over who could possibly show
it up based off of who Kevin feige has
worked with before and if you are
unaware Kevin feige has worked with
Marvel since the very first X-Men film
way back in the year 2000 which means
he's been working with Marvel Studios
even before then because we all know it
doesn't just take a few days to make a
movie so who can and will Kevin feige
bring back from his past into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and into the movie
Avengers Secret Wars that's what we'll
be going over today also a reminder
about the giveaway we're keeping it
going until the end of the year we'll
choose one more winner this week and
then next year we're going to keep going
with the giveaways as well so all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to the
channel leave a comment down below below
and in fact right now let me know who
you would like to see the most return
from a previous Marvel movie or show it
could be an X-Men A Fantastic Four
member it could be Agent Coulson anybody
let me know down below now to start off
let's acknowledge that pretty much
anybody could show up in Avengers Secret
Wars but today we're going to talk about
who realistically could show up now that
obviously includes anybody who is
currently alive in the MCU or who has
been alive before in the MCU the perfect
example is Robert Downey Jr will most
likely return playing some sort of
variant of himself in secret Wars the
same thing goes for Chris Evans
returning as Captain America Scarlett
Johansson returning as Black Widow and
so on and so forth and the chances of
them returning for Secret Wars for a
little Cameo is very very realistic so
anybody who is in the MCU or has been in
the MCU could pop up in secret Wars but
today we're going to be talking about
characters from other universes like I
mentioned characters who Kevin feige has
specifically worked for in the past and
of course we're going to be starting off
with the original X-Men the first
project that Kevin feige worked on in
2000 now rumor has it that this is a big
one for Kevin feige and yes while there
are many many different X-Men films over
in the fox Universe rumor has it that
the original X-Men from the original
X-Men Trilogy are going to be Kevin
feige's priority so that includes the
original X-Men movie X2 X-Men United and
of course X-Men the Last Stand and the
cool news is we're not just talking
about the heroes not just the actual
X-Men team but we're talking about the
main characters that appear in these
X-Men films with a heavy focus on the
original X-Men team and the bad guys so
of course Magneto and I'm assuming
Mystique would be along for the ride as
well but here's who we're talking about
showing up Patrick Stewart returning as
Charles Xavier who of course has already
returned in Multiverse of Madness and of
course Hugh Jackman returning as Logan
Wolverine who we will see return in
Deadpool 3. Ian McKellen as Magneto of
course he is Iconic it would be awesome
to see him return Halle Berry as storm
famka Jensen could return it depends on
when exactly they pulled them from the
timeline because of course as we know
she ends up dying however if they pull
her from the first or second film she
could definitely be in secret Wars same
thing goes with James marsden's Cyclops
he of course died but depending on when
the universes Collide he could also be
there as well and keep in mind it's
Kevin feige kind of saying his goodbye
to the original Fox X-Men so I would
expect the original team to show up even
though some of them are dead and of
course we can't forget Adam Paquin as
Rogue and of course Sean Ashmore could
even show up as Bobby Drake slash Iceman
and I'm assuming that's the original
X-Men team that's going to be pulled
into Secret Wars on top of course of
characters like James mcavoy's Professor
Xavier and of course with that comes
Michael fassbender's Magneto there's a
rumor that he was even supposed to be in
Multiverse of Madness but they never
ended up using the footage then I
suspect we could see Jennifer Lawrence
pop-up as Mystique now from there I do
think we could see other characters pop
up as different variants because I do
believe we are going to have many
different variants appear at the same
time that's why Kevin feige would bring
in both Patrick Stewart and James McAvoy
to play different variants of Professor
Xavier the same thing goes for Ian
McKellen and of course Michael
fassbender's magnetos the same thing
goes for Kelsey Grammar he could show up
as beast but Nicholas Holt could also
show up as Beast as well as far as what
realistically to expect I think this
main X-Men team and a few of these
characters from first class is what
we'll probably see in secret Wars but
the X-Men aren't the only people who are
going to be appearing in secret Wars
because Kevin feige worked on a lot more
movies including Spider-Man in 2002 now
of course we've already had Toby Maguire
Spider-Man return so I would expect to
see him again Toby Maguire did seem to
really have a blast being back and he
even said that himself that he was
really happy to come back and that he
would do it again and I think it would
be a big waste if he didn't return for
Secret Wars so I would expect Toby
Maguire Spider-Man now Kevin feige also
worked on the Daredevil movie this was
in 2003 with Ben Affleck and Jennifer
Garner who played Elektra now I know Ben
Affleck's Daredevil isn't the most loved
Daredevil of all time however it still
would be really cool to see him come on
screen along with Elektra and we're just
getting started with the movies there
are many more coming that we're going to
talk about but first a big thank you to
Mint mobile for sponsoring this video
most people know about mint mobile
because of Ryan Reynolds but most people
don't know about mint Mobile's amazing
quality now I live in the mountains and
service isn't too good however mint
mobile sent me a free plan and I get
better service with their plan than I do
with my other provider but what's crazy
is their plan is so much cheaper mint
mobile offers Wireless for just 15 bucks
a month they give you the best rate
whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint mobile families start
at only two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network plus mint Mobile's Modern
Family Plan lets you mix and match data
plans so everyone gets the amount of
data that's right for them and you can
use your own phone and keep your same
number and contacts so to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
including the Modern Family Plan go to
mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
build down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic now one movie I
want to mention is Ghost Rider with
Nicholas Cage Kevin feige seemingly
doesn't have any type of credits for
that movie at all however I would be
surprised if Nicholas Cage actually
didn't pop up in secret Wars I think
that his Ghost Rider was pretty iconic
whether you liked it or not Nicholas
Cage was a Ghostwriter for those movies
and if the rumor is true Marvel Studios
is planning on bringing a new Ghost
Rider into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so it would be cool to see Nicholas Cage
pop up alongside of the new Ghost Rider
as well but the next movie in the lineup
is the 2003 Hulk movie with Eric Bana
and not gonna lie it would be really
cool to see Eric Bana show up as the
Hulk from the 2003 Hulk movie alongside
of Mark Ruffalo and of course Edward
Norton who played the Incredible Hulk in
2008 which was technically a part of the
MCU it still technically is to this day
a part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so to see these three hulks together and
also She-Hulk alongside of them I think
that would be pretty cool and since
Kevin foggy worked on both of those
films and of course has worked with Mark
Ruffalo and She-Hulk I think it's a big
possibility then we have the 2004 The
Punisher film with Thomas Jane I think
this would be insanely cool for him to
show up and John bernthal's Punisher to
show up as well now we already have
Daredevil from the Netflix series who
has showed up Matt Murdoch Charlie Cox
and rumor has it that Jon Bernthal is
going to return as The Punisher in an
upcoming series perhaps the echo series
perhaps the Daredevil Series so I think
it would be really really cool if we saw
John Bernthal next to Thomas Jane's The
Punisher now then of course we have
Spider-Man 2 and Spider-Man 3. now we
already know that Toby Maguire is most
likely coming back but however like I
mentioned they're also probably going to
bring in some villains as well there was
a rumor a while ago and I don't know how
credible this is so just take it as a
unreliable Rumor for now but the rumor
stated that Topher Grace was going to
return as Venom honestly I wouldn't mind
seeing it especially if Tom Hardy could
make his way over for Secret Wars in his
version of Venom and I think that would
be really cool because one of them would
be bad and one of them would be good one
of them would fight with Kang and the
other fight with the Avengers and the
X-Men the Fantastic Four and so on plus
not to mention if Tom Hardy's Venom came
we could see him fight alongside of the
other Spider-Man which I think would be
really cool as well now here's something
that's really interesting that I don't
actually know how it's going to go down
if it does happen but Kevin feige was a
part of the original Blade movies with
Wesley Snipes now Wesley Snipes has kind
of gotten into some trouble over time so
I'm not sure Marvel Studios would want
to bring him back however with
mahershala Ali about to be the new blade
in the MCU it would be cool to see him
alongside of Wesley Snipes and something
else that would be really really cool to
see is Deadpool and Ryan reynolds's
character from blade Trinity Hannibal
King together on screen yes Ryan
Reynolds was in the original Blade
franchise and you know Deadpool wouldn't
mention that and make fun of it now the
next movie is Elektra from 2005 but like
I already mentioned for Daredevil
electric could return and the next movie
after that which many fans might not
know even exist is man thing which came
out in 2005. now we just had man thing
be introduced in the MCU in werewolf by
night so again it would be really cool
to see two variants of one character
standing next to each other in secret
Wars and then of course the big ones the
Fantastic Four films now rumor has it
from insiders right now that the
original Fantastic Four and some of the
original X-Men are going to appear in
Deadpool 3. this will lead them to the
MCU making their way to appear in secret
Wars now since we are getting getting a
new Fantastic Four team in the MCU very
soon I would be absolutely shocked if we
didn't see the old original Fantastic
Four team especially since Chris Evans
played the Human Torch that's a big
opportunity to see Chris Evans on screen
as Captain America and as the Human
Torch which I think everybody would
absolutely love so I would definitely
expect the original Fantastic Four team
to be in secret Wars however one thing I
am not sure is if the 2015 Fantastic
Four team will show up the movie wasn't
received very well by fans and Kevin
feige really didn't have anything to do
with that movie and I'm not really sure
it would cause much of a wow factor and
in this case I think the old original
Fantastic Four with Jessica Alba showing
up next to our new Fantastic Four team
would be more than enough to make fans
ah so I wouldn't actually expect a 2015
Fantastic Four team to show up and with
those final movies that takes us to the
creation of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with Iron Man starting in 2008
and like I said anyone from the MCU even
if if they are still dead Our Fair Game
to show up in Avengers Secret Wars but
this is our list of previous superheroes
who could realistically show up in
Avengers Secret Wars in fact I would
expect many of them to show up but let
us know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and let us know who
you would like to see show up more than
anybody else leave your thoughts down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign